en este vídeo vamos a hacer algunos
ejemplos de problemas de funciones
algunos estudiantes se les complica un
poco este tema pero en el fondo cuando
entendemos bien que es una función pues
ya los ejemplos se ven bastante fáciles
así que déjame platicar primero de las
funciones una función básicamente es una
asociación entre variables por ejemplo
podemos decir que ya es igual a efe de
equis y lo que esto quiere decir es que
si ponemos un valor de x entonces esta
función como que se lo come lo agarra de
entrada y después de aplicarle ciertas
reglas produce un valor y también
podemos pensar esto visualmente como
como una caja de sorpresas por ejemplo
si aquí tenemos una caja que es la
función f
pues entonces le estamos metiendo x como
valor y a cambio después de aplicarle
ciertas reglas obtenemos el valor que o
bien el valor f x hasta ahorita esto
está muy abstracto porque no tenemos una
función así específica déjame poner un
ejemplo voy a
este color verde entonces imaginemos que
nos dicen que la función efe de x está
dada por lo siguiente tenemos tres casos
la función fx va a ser igual a 1 si x es
igual a 0 si x es igual a 0 va a ser
igual a 2 si x es igual a 1 y va a ser
igual a 3 en otro caso en otro caso caso
entonces estoy acá sería nuestra caja de
sorpresas vale
ahí está la caja de sorpresas eso es lo
que está sucediendo adentro de este
recuadro entonces lo voy a pintar por
acá el recuadro también
y entonces lo que sucede es que si aquí
metemos un valor x obtenemos a cambio un
valor
fx por ejemplo imagínate que nos piden
determinar el valor el valor del cdf de
7 entonces que tendríamos que hacer aquí
en la caja tendríamos que meter 7 y
entonces este 7 entra y tenemos que
checar las regletas 707 no es 1 entonces
caemos al otro caso y por lo tanto la
regleta nos daría de regreso a un 3 sale
entonces efe de 7 sería igual a 3 porque
caemos en este caso de acá ahora qué
sucede si ponemos digamos un 2 entonces
queremos determinar cuánto es efe de 2
pues ahora este 2 entraría y ahora a
mira vuelve a caer al otro caso porque
no es ni cero ni uno entonces estamos en
en otro caso y obtenemos de nuevo un 3
entonces efe dedos también es 3 pero por
ejemplo para para usar las otras reglas
si pusiéramos efe de 1
esto querría decir que metemos un 1 es
básicamente como una computadora le
metes un valor checa las regletas vale 0
no vale 1 sí entonces estamos en este
caso y por lo tanto nos da de regreso
ahora un 2 entonces obtenemos que f 1 es
igual a 2 bueno este ejemplo está padre
pero vamos a hacer algunos ejemplos y de
aquí de los problemas para agarrarle un
poco más la onda esto de las funciones
vale mira entonces el problema dice para
cada una de las funciones y aquí nos dan
tres funciones evalúa efe de menos tres
efe 7 efe de 0 y fcc está muy bien
entonces es exactamente la misma idea de
aquí arriba vamos a empezar con con este
con el 1 entonces voy a ponerlo en
amarillo
la uno dice fx es igual a menos 2 x 3
entonces queremos encontrar efe - tres
de siete de cero y de zeta bueno si
queremos encontrar
efe de menos 3 la idea es que aquí
tenemos que poner en vez de x menos 3
entonces déjame ponerle f de menos 3 lo
voy a poner con otro color para que sea
más más claro lo que estoy haciendo
entonces
efe de menos 3 que tendríamos que hacer
pues aquí donde dice x le ponemos menos
3 entonces nos quedaría menos 2 x menos
3 x menos 3 ese es el valor de x y luego
tenemos que sumar 3
3 vamos a ver cuánto nos da esto menos 2
x menos 32 por 13 6 menos por menos es
más entonces nos queda 6 + 3 y 6 3 es
igual a 9 entonces efe de menos 3 es
igual a 9 siguiendo esta idea de la caja
aquí tenemos la función f déjame ponerla
por aquí arribita
que tenemos la función efe le pusimos de
entrada del valor menos tres menos tres
y de salida obtuvimos el valor nueve
vale entonces efe - 3 es igual a 9 vamos
ahora con efe de 7 misma idea
efe de 7 lo voy a poner aquí abajo efe
de 7 efe de 7 lo voy a poner con otro
color con rojo
efe de 7 es igual a menos 2 por 7 nos
quedaría menos 2 x 7 y a eso tenemos que
sumarle tres más tres menos dos por 7 es
menos 14 si a menos 14 le sumamos 3 nos
queda menos 11 muy bien misma idea
metemos el 7 y nos da menos 11 vamos con
efe de 0
efe de 0 me voy a quedar en color
amarillo
efe de 0 es menos 2 por 0 + 3 cualquier
cosa por cervecero esto nos queda cero
así que f de 0 es igual a 3 y finalmente
tenemos algo un poco más interesante nos
piden calcular
efe dz efe dz ahora no tenemos un valor
sino una variable déjame ponerla en
color rojo para entonces queremos
determinar
efe de z y es exactamente exactamente la
misma idea difícil zeta
sale simplemente ahora en vez de tener
una equis ponemos la zeta entonces nos
quedaría menos 2 por zeta por zeta ceta
ya eso tenemos que sumarle 3
3 entonces si pensamos en la caja
aquí tenemos efe
entra z entra z y a cambio obtenemos
menos 2 z menos 2 z más 3 muy bien
entonces con esto terminamos el primer
problema no voy a saltar el segundo la
segunda función para que la intentes tú
pero también por cuestiones de tiempo
entonces déjame pasar al tercero lo voy
a hacer con color verde va entonces
vamos a la tercera función entonces qué
tenemos que hacer misma idea sustituimos
estos valores en esta en esta expresión
y vemos que nos queda entonces para el 3
el primero nos dice que queremos
encontrar efe de menos 3
efe de menos 3 entonces la expresión es
5 x 2 - x entre 11 entonces tendríamos
que hacer 5 x
2 - menos 3
/ / 11 2 - menos 3 es lo mismo que 23
aquí tenemos un 5
entonces esto de aquí sería igual a 25
entre 11 déjame bajar un poquito para
tener más espacio ok
efe - 3 es 25 11 a 2 vamos con efe de 7
efe de 7 es igual a 5 por 2 menos 7
entre 11
311 a ver 27 es menos 5 menos 5 por 5 es
menos 25 entonces aquí tendríamos menos
25 onceavos menos 25 entre 11 muy bien
ya nada más nos quedan 2
efe de 0 y efe dz efe de 0 lo voy a
hacer de este lado
efe de 0
es igual a misma ideal 5 por 2 0 / / 11
/ 11 20 es 25 por 12 10
nos queda 10 11 a bosch y finalmente
para encontrar efe dz pues nada más
cambiamos la equis por zeta nos quedaría
igual a 5 x 2 menos zeta ceta 27 z entre
11 muy bien esto lo podríamos
desarrollar un poquito más 5 x 12 10 5
por menos z es menos 5 z y aquí podemos
dividir entre 11 e incluso podemos
partirlo dividiendo entre 11
distribuyendo esta división nos quedaría
lo voy a poner así como menos 5 entre 11
por zeta use primero este término para
poner primero lo que tiene zeta y luego
vamos a sumar
10 11 años fantástico entonces con esto
terminamos el inciso 3 ahora hay otro
tipo de ejercicios que me gustaría que
vieras que los tengo aquí abajo va antes
déjame platicarte una cosa las funciones
como te acabo de decir son como cajas
que reciben un valor reciben un valor
valor equis y a cambio nos dan un valor
efe de equis o bien un valor y vale
entonces aquí está la función f pero
este valor que nos dan es único no se
puede que nos den más que nos haga que
nos den más de un valor por ejemplo si
tuviéramos una función que se llama efe
de equis y está definida así
fx es igual a 3 si x es igual a 0 y a 4
sí sí si x es igual a 0 entonces
tendríamos un problema porque efe de 0
no lo podríamos determinar quién es
quién sabe nos dice que es 3 o 4 pero no
sabemos exactamente quién es esto es un
problema entonces esta de acá y estoy
acá no es una función va se parece a una
función pero no lo es para cada valor
solo podemos tener un posible resultado
entonces una pregunta es cuáles de estas
gráficas son gráficas de funciones bueno
pues la idea para checar si son gráficas
de funciones o no es tomarnos cada uno
de los puntos en x y trazar una línea
vertical entonces si esa línea vertical
solo toca en un punto a la gráfica que
nos están dando eso quiere decir que
para cada valor de x solo hay un valor
de ye ye igual
entonces no hay problema por ejemplo en
esta primera en esta primera gráfica
pues no importa que en línea vertical
trazamos siempre tocamos a la gráfica
solo en un punto en este acá en este de
acá o en este de acá y por lo tanto si
podemos definir una función a partir de
esta gráfica esta de aquí si sería la
gráfica de una función pero aquí tenemos
un problema por ejemplo si tomamos este
valor de x y trazamos una línea vertical
aquí tenemos dos posibles valores para
que este de aquí y este de acá entonces
eso no nos permite definir una función
por qué no poder porque para este valor
de x no hay un valor único de iu que
funcione entonces está de acá no sería
no sería la gráfica de una función misma
idea con esta gráfica aquí tenemos esta
línea vertical o si quieres ésta hay
varias que tienen problema pero digamos
esta última que pinte hace que este y
este sean posibles valores para que y
por lo tanto esto no es la gráfica de
una función y esta de acá que es una
palomita pues estaba acá si es gráfica
de función digo está un poco chistosa
pero no importa qué línea vertical atrás
hemos siempre la interfecta en uno y
sólo un punto entonces esta última que
es una palomita le ponemos palomita ajá
porque también es la gráfica de una
función bueno le voy a dejar hasta aquí
nos vemos hasta la próxima